didier ouédraogo il est philosophe et
président de la section de france du
mouvement des droits de l'homme et des
peuples du burkina faso didier ouedraogo
bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors on le disait un des
élections sous tension entre un climat
d'insécurité et des menaces de
l'opposition de ne pas reconnaître les
résultats
est ce qu'on peut craindre des violences
dans les heurts dans les jours qui
viennent
mais oui en chine accroît et de l'espoir
aux différentes dispositions en tout cas
les informations qui parviennent un
petit peu et il faut souhaiter que ça
n'avait pas plu à des suspicions de
fraudes et que cela ne s'est pas avérée
afin que l'on puisse quand même à aller
jusqu'au bout du processus électoral
dans dans un climat beaucoup plus serein
parce que on sait bien sûr l'attention
et on peut craindre effectivement que
ces tensions avec des éléments comme
save actuels qui peuvent être repérés
par ci par là ne conduise à un niveau de
violence qu'on n'aurait pas souhaité et
que personne ne souhaite
alors vous en parliez à l'opposition des
craintes des fraudes massives et menace
même de ne pas reconnaître les résultats
en cas de victoire dès le premier tour
du président sortant
c'est quoi c'est une façon de faire
monter la pression ou le risque de
fraude est une réalité et si oui par
quels moyens
alors si vous voulez bien sûr on ne peut
pas savoir si vraiment les risques qui
sont énoncées par l'opposition sont
avérés mais toujours est il que pour
prévenir justement cette situation de
fraude possible parce que rien exclu
effectivement des fraudes un bon mais je
n'ai pas d'indicateurs précis comme ça
pour vous donner pour vous dire que des
fraudes existent vous n'existeront pas
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que le
procureur ait général d'évoquer la façon
et auprès du tribunal de grande instance
de bordeaux a sorti un communiqué ce
matin pour éviter effectivement prévenir
que toute suspicion ou toute fraude qui
seraient avérées être ramener
directement donc devant les tribunaux et
par toute personne qui serait d'une
portée donc décidé ce ticket moyen d
user des moyens pour que les choses se
mettent bien en place et que
effectivement on puisse régler les
choses par la voie judiciaire et dans
par donc des méthodes qu'ils seraient
contraires et contre la vertu
démocratique donc par la voix jeudi
hier pas forcément besoin de la
communauté internationale comme le
demandait l'opposition qu'on a entendu
dans ce journal
mais la communauté internationale
n'intervient que si effectivement la
communauté nationale n'est pas en mesure
de régler cette question puisque c'est
d'avoir une question nationale vous en
conviendrez avec moi
donc si la communauté de nationale 2
effectivement les voies de recours
nationaux national pardon n'aurait pas
aidé suffisament pour juguler les crises
qui auraient été tentés 10 mois pointe
est avérée et cetera ou en tout cas est
mis sur le tapis pour être élu
alors en tout cas le terrorisme et ses
conséquences c'est bien l'enjeu majeur
de ce scrutin l'actuel président est
favori roch marc christian kaboré est ce
qu'il ya une stratégie qui fonctionne
encore aujourd'hui pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
voici la une il faudrait peut être qu'il
l'ait fait savoir parce que pour
l'instant c'était nous allons compter
sur le terrain s'est créé les
terroristes continuent quand même ne
savait donc le trouble désordre et la
mort d'un ado paix dans notre pays et
que pour l'instant on n'arrive pas tout
à fait à juguler à part effectivement de
temps en temps quelques poches donc de
de résistance et qui permettent donc de
désamorcer quelques quelques les hits et
donc d'attaquer cetera
mais toujours est il que pour l'instant
ce que nous constatons sur le terrain
c'est une grande difficulté une grosse
difficulté pour la population et bien
sûr pour l'événement donc à mettre fin
ou en tout cas à contenir
donc les verts de violence et les vardon
de les terroriser les docteurs multiples
qui se font en fait de manière très
aléatoire est très imprévisible
bien sûr vous en conviendrez mais en
même temps qui permette de 1,3
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons pas savoir
où est-ce qu'on a on va avec cette
affaire parce que au jour le jour qui
passe nous continuerons de mettre un
petit peu plus de torpeur de violence et
de mort dans notre territoire et cette
impossibilité de résoudre cette question
terroriste
elle est plus lié à une stratégie ou un
roi un manque de moyens mais peut-être
il faudrait peut-être penser les deux en
même temps parce que c'est une question
nationale
donc comme vous savez 5 est elle donc
et en fait régler la question du
terrorisme sur le cerveau qui n'avait ne
permettrait peut-être pas dans le réseau
de la question de manière globale pour
le burkina parce que de toute façon les
attaques venaient d'ailleurs donc c'est
une question de stratégie parce qu'il
faut arrêter une stratégie globale
mais en même temps et quant à la
question des moyens ça va ensemble parce
que la stratégie définit aussi des
moyens qu'ils ont eu à être plus adéquat
pour ont calé contre bien que cette
hydre donc du terrorisme et je pense
aussi savoir que les moyens et sont
toujours attendus et qu'il n'y en a pas
assez
moi en quoi bien sûr qu'elle veut
témoignages et puis bien sûr la
communauté internationale dans l'aide
peut-être aussi conditionnée par un
certain nombre de choses et donc je suis
certainement cette affaire donc même de
de canderel des plans militaire et
cetera de résistance et la programmation
militaire précisément mon problème à
cette programmation ne produit pas
beaucoup d'effet pour revenir au scrutin
parmi les 12 concurrents de sortent du
lot zéphirin diabré eddie komboïgo il
n'y a jamais eu de second tour à une
élection présidentielle au burkina est
ce que cette fois ça peut être le cas
ben écoute et ne sais pas et il n'est
pas une boîte de thé faire pour vous
dire les résultats de ce saoudien
mais ce que je sens c'est que
l'opposition semble aller très marrant
beaucoup plus serré et que justement ça
pourrait peut-être effectivement changé
la donne habituel qui est de un seul
tour qu'on appelle est
malencontreusement coup ko et cetera
dans une élection dont on ne doit pas
penser qu'il y a quelqu'un comme hétéro
mais plutôt un pays qui cherche un
président pour diriger donc sa destinée
pendant cinq ans j étant bien évidemment
aujourd'hui nous pensons que
l'opposition et haras à peu près bien
serré et que peut être cela donnerait
quelque chose alors l'élection ne peut
pas se tenir sur moi un cinquième du
territoire à cause de la crainte
d'attaqués djihadistes on en parlait à
l'instant
est-ce que ce manque de voix peut
changer le scrutin il y a pendant ce
scrutin à cette élection n'aura pas se
tenir sur au moins un cinquième du
territoire à cause de la crainte d'
attaque jihadiste est ce que ce manque
de voir peut changer la donne dans ce
scrutin se marre de voix déjà posé une
question si vous voulez dans priest donc
de la démocratie globalement parce qu'il
va falloir comprendre que si un
cinquième du pays qui ne votent pas y
quelque part un déficit démocratique que
c'était un premier élément est le second
élément est que effectivement des voix
pour évoquer à la fois pour les uns et
les autres candidats en tout cas
prétendants au pouvoir
donc en réalité il s'agit peut-être pas
donc devoir privilégier tel ou tel
candidat mais globalement il est des
voies qui vont manquer à l'appel donc de
ce walk
merci beaucoup didier ouedraogo d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes philosophe et président de la
section de france du mouvement des
droits de l'homme et des peuples du
burkina faso